Türkei ist die Zukunft das haben wir
jetzt alle mittlerweile schon mal gehört
darum soll es heute nicht gehen Ich will
heute herausfinden wie gut funktioniert
ist wirklich ein Tag lang das Essen
durch künstliche Intelligenz bestimmen
zu lassen und das heißt nicht gib mir
ein Rezept macht das sondern wir
probieren heute alles als allererstes
lass ich mir ein Restaurant empfehlen
dann lasse ich mir einen Gericht
vorgeben und dann lasse ich mir sagen wo
ich heute etwas zu Essen bestellen soll
mit anderen Worten wir sehen uns zurück
und lassen Chat GPT arbeiten dafür hole
ich erstmal mein Handy raus so ich habe
hier schon mal ein Fenster geöffnet und
wir schreiben einfach mal rein wo kann
ich heute etwas in Köln frühstücken
Fragezeichen gerne etwas Exotisches
Punkt in Köln gibt es viele Cafés und
Restaurants die ein leckeres Frühstück
anbieten wenn Sie auf der Suche nach
etwas exotischen Sinn könnte das Kaffee
Schmitz eine gute Wahl sein hier können
Sie einen orientalisches Frühstück mit
Falafel Hummus und Oliven und anderen
Köstlichkeit okay wir haben drei
verschiedene Spots vorgeschlagen
bekommen die auch wirklich schön
ausgearbeitet sind ich finde das immer
wieder beeindruckend also ich habe
selbst noch nicht super viel gemacht mit
Intelligenz aber jetzt mal ehrlich wenn
du jetzt in einer anderen Stadt wärst wo
du dich gar nicht auskennst und würdest
so ein hochwertiges Input bekommen was
willst du mehr das ist jetzt schon
geiler als Google als TripAdvisor das
fühlt sich fast schon so ein bisschen an
wie so eine Empfehlung eines Freundes ja
absolut weil auch so geil ausformuliert
ist ganz ehrlich Kaffee Schmitz kenne
ich da gehe ich abends gerne mal hin für
einen Drink so das Frühstück kenne ich
noch gar nicht und ich finde Humus
Oliven andere Köstlichkeiten da kann man
auch so schön an der Straße sitzen
erzähl mir mehr zu Kaffee Schmitz das
Kaffee Schmitz ist eine beliebte Adresse
in Köln die vier orientalisches
Frühstück und ihre gemütliche Atmosphäre
bekannt ist
Interieur des Cafés ist im
orientalischen Stil gehalten nein
also die KI hat sich jetzt ein bisschen
auf das orientalische Frühstück
eingeschossen weil da gibt's halt alles
nicht da gibt's auch so mehr Geld da
gibt's aber auch ranola Bowl und so also
ihr merkt schon das ist nicht perfekt
ich sage euch ehrlich habe richtig Lust
auf dieses orientalische Frühstück
bekommen deshalb würde ich sagen ab
geht's zu Kaffee Schmitz dort holen wir
uns genau das
[Musik]
wir sind da Café Schmitz französisches
Frühstück Frühstück klassisch Falafel
sehe ich hier noch nicht wir gehen mal
rein und Fragen mal wir haben
nachgefragt Falafel gibt es aktuell nur
zur Mittagszeit also check gptiva falsch
informiert ein orientalisches Frühstück
gibt es aber das bestellen wir auch
gucken wir mal wie nah das dem kommt was
zertifizier uns gesagt hat
drei pochierte Bio-Eier oder hier mit
Marrakesch drei mädges zwei pochierte
Bio-Eier Gewürz Tomatensoße Geschmack
Papier und Petersilie dazu gegrilltes
Brot Butter und Limetten Hummus
würde ich sagen noch exotischer und
kommt auf dem von Jet GPT gefährlich
nach ja es gibt halt statt Falafel
vergessen wir bestellen hier haben wir
jetzt unsere von der KI vorgeschlagene
orientalische exotische
frühstücksspezialität
gibt es leider nicht wir haben aber mehr
Gäste oben drauf drei Stück an der Zeit
zwei pochierte Eier in so einer
Schmorpfanne so bisschen
Paprika drin oben drauf Petersilie oder
Koriander das hier ist ein limettenmus
und hier das klassische orientalische
Sauerteigbrot ist so gehen wir einmal
rein in die Masse gucken
[Musik]
schöne frische es ist jetzt wirklich ein
Spot zu dem ich persönlich nicht zum
Frühstücken gekommen wäre weil ich das
halt total so mit Nightlife Drinks und
sowas verbinde hier im Prinzip habe ich
jetzt quasi durch das Tool was neues
ausprobiert mein Repertoire erweitert
wer weiß vielleicht empfehle ich bald
mal jemandem diesen Spot hier Stichwort
exotisch kriegst du auch nicht in jedem
frühstückskaffeest meines im Prinzip
schönes Wort für Bratwurst aber wir
probieren
schöner Lamm Geschmack geil richtig
richtig gut exotisches Frühstück haben
wir alle meine leckeres Frühstück haben
wir alle mal Empfehlung funktionieren
aber in dem Fall muss der Typ hier auch
nicht verstehen was gut schmeckt was gut
zusammen passt bei Mittagessen schon und
dafür dass wir uns jetzt ein Rezept
geben zurück im Studio jetzt geht es um
das Mittagessen wie gesagt möchte ich
jetzt Kochen deshalb lassen wir uns ein
Rezept geben ich bin gerade bisschen
hier im Fitness Modus deshalb habe ich
die gute Idee mir mal so ein Fitness
optimiert das Gericht ausgeben zu lassen
gib mir ein Rezept für einen
ausgewogenes gesundes Gericht mit
mindestens 50 g Protein es muss bitte
asiatisch sein Ausrufezeichen also wenn
ich dich jetzt fragen würde dann würdest
du jetzt erstmal so fünf Minuten
überlegen gebraten die Hähnchenbrust mit
Gemüse und Reis wir gehen einkaufen und
dann stellen wir uns hinter den Herd und
hier sind alle Zutaten es sieht schon
mal echt nicht verkehrt aus und ehrlich
zu sein ich weiß nicht ob die den Job
mit Restaurants und Rezepten nicht sogar
besser macht als ich und auch in der
Vergangenheit sind Jobs durch
Technologisierung bedroht worden klar
Menschen finden dann immer Mittel und
Wege aber auch durch Unfall und
Krankheit kann es natürlich passieren
dass man Probleme bekommt und dann im
schlimmsten Fall im Alter nicht richtig
abgesichert ist aus diesem Grund habe
ich Chat GPT gefragt wie ich persönlich
mich am besten im Alter versichern kann
und das kam dabei raus private
Vorsorgeprodukte sind super wichtig
schützen uns später vor Altersarmut und
stocken unsere Rente auf gerade wenn man
selbstständig ist wie ich es bin aber
auch das gesetzliche Rentensystem hat
natürlich seine Probleme ich meine jeder
vierte geht davon aus dass das
Rentensystem irgendwann zusammenbrechen
kann und da ist private Vorsorge eine
super Option aber was kann ich jetzt tun
um gut fürs Alter vorzusorgen bei der
Altersvorsorge gibt es viele
verschiedene Möglichkeiten und klar kann
euch dabei helfen euch zu sagen was für
euch die beste ist mit dem rentenkopf
wird von klar könnt ihr ganz individuell
eure Rentenlücke herausfinden und eine
passende Absicherung finden so könnt ihr
sicherstellen dass ihr im Alter
finanziell abgesichert seid klagt
dürften viele von euch schon kennen
falls nein hier eine kurze Erklärung
klar ist ein digitaler
versicherungsmanager bei dem ihr alle
eure Versicherung
gebündelt einsehen könnt in der App
könnt ihr einen individuellen
bedarfscheck machen und zu sehen wie gut
ihr bereits versichert seid und sie
bietet euch unter 180 Versicherern den
für euch besten Dealern wenn ihr euch
neue anmeldet könnt ihr meinen Code Max
pane benutzen und wenn ihr drei
bestehende Versicherung hoch ladet könnt
ihr einen 45 Euro best choice Gutschein
bekommen man muss keine neuen
Versicherung bei Clark abschließen kann
sich aber unabhängig und kostenlos
beraten lassen ist ja nicht meine erste
Zusammenarbeit mit Clark und da kommen
immer wieder Fragen auf ihr gebt klar
wenn ihr euch anmeldet ein maklermandat
wenn ihr also bisher ein Makler habt
dann würde der quasi nicht mehr für euch
zuständig sein sondern klagt vertritt
euch aus transparenzgründen das ist kein
Geheimnis sondern das ist einfach nötig
damit klar für euch operieren kann
scannt also jetzt den QR-Code oder geht
über meinen Link vergesst nicht den Code
und lasst euch von Clark unverbindlich
zu Altersvorsorge beraten fangen wir
aber direkt an mit dem Kochen ich habe
jetzt zwei Hähnchenbrüste ich glaube
Proteinbedarf ist damit definitiv
gedeckt ich trenne hier einmal die
innenbrustfilets ab und schneide dann
alles überschüssige ab und als nächstes
schn Eide ich die Hähnchenbrust in
mundgerechte Stücke das wirklich geil
dass man auch höchsten step by step
guide bekommen ne also man muss einfach
nur das Rezept befolgen the future ist
now
was denkst du wie viel Protein hat das
mit zwei hähnchenbrüsten insgesamt 500
Gramm dann haben wir 100 über 100 km/h
also doppelte Portion ist das aber
definitiv auch falls euch das übrigens
interessiert sobald ich halbwegs
präsentable Ergebnisse erzielt habe
hätte ich auch Lust und Videos zu machen
so über Ernährung jetzt wo ich selbst
ein bisschen Sport mache und so weil da
habe ich auch schon vieles neu gelernt
also wenn es quasi darum geht wie ist
man clean die Videos sind für mich so
quasi meine Cheat Dates schreibt man in
die Kommentare ob das was wäre was euch
auch interessiert einen Tag Fitness food
oder das habe ich gegessen um auszusehen
die Markus Rühl next step Teriyaki Soße
und Olivenöl hinzufügen und gut
vermischen zwei Esslöffel Olivenöl und
zwei Esslöffel Teriyaki Soße das ist
eine mit Sesam es gab nur die beim
Supermarkt kein Problem einfach dazu so
viel eigenes handlungsvermögen lassen
wir uns heute mal übrig einmal schön
durchmassieren das Hähnchen mariniert so
ein bisschen saugt den Geschmack auf und
lässt sich natürlich gleich auch schön
anbraten durch das Fett wie lange muss
das Einwirken
30 Minuten dann sehen wir uns gleich ich
würde sagen wir machen noch mal den
Reiskocher anders
perfekt das stimmt Vollkornreis doppelte
Menge Wasser dazu so ein bisschen Salz
noch dran hier mit der
Box wenn ihr schon ganz neugierig seid
wegen dieses blockschilds ein kleiner
Zusammenhang ist vielleicht jetzt schon
zu erkennen da kommt bald was können
auch mal auf insta rein folgen oder in
der Beschreibung den Link checken für
den Newsletter schnippeln wir schon mal
das Gemüse die Karotte bzw die Möhre
können wir in Scheiben schneiden hinten
vorne einmal ab Paprika in Streifen und
Brokkoli Röschen los geht's
[Musik]
halbe Stunde später das Hähnchen ist
mariniert ich gebe es in die Pfanne und
dort brät es jetzt bei mittlerer Hitze
ihr hört noch nicht allzu viel so bleibt
es auch für 10 Minuten das finde ich
schon sportlich also ist relativ lange
durch wird es glaube ich alle mal sein
ich meine muss man sich auch mal
vorstellen ne im Prinzip ist das auch
irgendwo gefährlich so eine KI sich ein
Rezept geben zu lassen weil wenn er
jetzt stehen wir eine brat das für eine
Minute dann ist das Hähnchen in der
Mitte gerade vom Sesam kommt schon
direkt so ein geräuchertes Aroma
Teriyaki gemacht kein weiteres Öl in die
Pfanne wir bleiben beim fitnessgericht
erstmal braten wir das jetzt goldgelb
und durch nicht vergessen gelegentlich
zu rühren 10 Minuten sind vorbei unser
Hähnchen ist gebraten stellen ist zur
Seite in eine Schüssel wo wir es ruhen
lassen jetzt nehmen wir die gleiche
Pfanne erst zwiebeln und Knoblauch und
wenn das weich ist dann gehen den Rest
hinzu das sieht schon traurig aus sieht
sehr traurig aus oder auch so ohne Öl
ich meine
scheinbar sehr ernst genommen dass wir
gerne Fitness fettarm das ganze machen
wollen und gesund
oder verbrenn das zuerst weiß ich jetzt
auch nicht ich bin ein selbstdenkender
Mensch und ich machen klein bisschen Öl
dran noch können wir nicht komplett
aufhören selbst zu denken jetzt ist es
langsam weich und ich gebe die Möhren
dazu wenn ich mir das jetzt angucke
denke ich mir dann boah geil oder denkst
du mir dann
Fitness food ich glaube eher 5 Fitness
food na ja es ist halt die Aufgabe
ausgeführt ne es kann schon auch lecker
sein da haben wir lecker in der prompt
verwendet nein
unser Reis ist fertig den nehmen wir uns
einmal was davon wollen wir zwei Tassen
ich mache einfach nach Auge Klasse 1
Klasse 2 Hähnchen wieder dazu noch mal
ein zwei Minuten mit erhitzen und
bisschen Salz Pfeffer dran steht da das
sind minimum 2 Portion das steht aber
auch nicht da ne und das Essen ist
fertig guckt euch an wir garnieren das
ganze noch mit ein bisschen fein
geschnittener Frühlingszwiebel so ich
probiere einmal hier unser Hähnchen das
hat ja eigentlich nicht viel dran was es
besonders machen würde
bisschen Ingwer Soja da ist ja schon
viel von der asiatischen Küche mit drin
auch wenn ich immer so ein bisschen Reis
mit Gemüse nehme eine Couch schon etwas
länger drauf drücken oder auf jeden Fall
nach seinen 5 Minuten noch ordentlich
bist ja das ist jetzt kein Gericht was
super viel Spaß macht wir waren jetzt im
Restaurant wir haben selber gekocht
gucken wir mal was uns Jet GPT empfiehlt
wenn wir heute Abend etwas Leckeres
bestellen wollen bisher hat die
künstliche Intelligenz ihre Aufgabe
wirklich gut gemacht in Schulnoten würde
ich vielleicht mit zwei geben weil
teilweise war es ein bisschen verwirrend
und es hat noch ein bisschen was gefehlt
bis es richtig gut gewesen wäre aber ich
kann mich nicht beklagen ich koche
allerdings nicht nur gerne und gehen
nicht nur gerne essen nein ich bestelle
auch sehr gerne und auch ihr seht immer
gerne wenn ich bestelle deshalb frage
ich jetzt mal ob es eine Empfehlung für
einen bestellspot gibt wo kann ich in
Köln etwas leckeres zu Essen bestellen
hier sind einige Empfehlung weil
lieferando.de oder Lieferando App können
sich viele Restaurants ja okay bei
welchem Restaurant in Köln kann ich ein
leckeres Pastagericht bestellen
Korea siciliana und Belgischen Viertel
kenne ich gar nicht sondern wir sind nur
in belgischen unterwegs eigentlich wie
kann ich bei Trattoria siciliana
bestellen jetzt bin ich gespannt
lieferplattform tattooaciciana ist auch
auf verschiedenen lieferplattformen wie
lieferando.de oder deliveroo vertreten
deliveroo gibt es schon längst nicht
mehr ich glaube die libro wurde vor drei
Jahren oder sowas aufgekauft von Little
Hero der vielleicht gibt's auch diese
Trattoria siciliana gar nicht mehr ich
guck mal kurz es gibt in Sülz eine
Trattoria siciliana aber sicherlich im
Belgischen Viertel
was ganz anderes sag mir wo es den
besten Burger in Köln gibt und welchen
ich bestellen soll Freddy Schilling das
Restaurant bietet eine große Auswahl an
handgemachten Burger mit hochwertigen
Zutaten ich würde den Freddy Deluxe
Burger empfehlen gucken wir mal ob es
den auch wirklich gibt es gibt kein
Freddy Deluxe es gibt keinen nein
welchen Burger kannst du mir bei Freddy
Schilling in Köln empfehlen einer der
beliebtesten Burger bei
Freddy Deluxe welchen Burger kannst du
mir noch empfehlen French Connection
empfehlen French
nein es gibt kein French Connection
kannst du mir noch einen weiteren Burger
bei Freddie Schilling empfehlen
Fragezeichen ich kann dir den Black
Angus Burger von Freddy Schillinger
empfehlen den gibt es auch nicht oder
kannst du mir einen weiteren Burger bei
Freddy Schilling empfehlen wie wäre es
mit dem Blue Cheeseburger gibt's nicht
okay Leute wir sitzen jetzt schon 15
Minuten daran irgendwas brauchbares aus
tschechische TT hervorzukitzeln und es
klappt einfach nicht scheinbar ist für
diesen Anwendungsfall die künstliche
Intelligenz noch nicht weit genug aber
wer weiß vielleicht sieht das ja in
Zukunft anders aus wir lassen uns jetzt
einfach gut sein wir stellen uns keine
Ahnung worauf wir Lust haben irgendwas
bestimmt ist ich glaube es war trotzdem
sehr interessant zu sehen wie gut das
ganze heute schon wirklich funktioniert
wie gut die Gerichte sind wie gut die
Restaurantempfehlungen sind und wie
scheiße die lieferdienstempfehlungen
sind ja das soll es gewesen sein ich
hoffe es war trotzdem interessant für
euch jetzt großen Spaß gemacht und ich
glaube ich werde es auch wenn das jetzt
frustrierend war wirklich wirklich auch
im Alltag benutzen einfach so ich habe
das im Kühlschrank was kann ich kochen
übelst chillig
bleibt gut tschüss